in Spain to China other nations
recognize that the country that leads
the clean energy economy would be the
country that leads the 21st century
global economy many of our elected
leaders enthusiastically supports
renewable energy transitioning to
renewables like wind and solar they tell
us will reduce greenhouse gas emissions
advanced renewable technology and best
of all create green jobs green jobs are
gonna be you know the next big thing
well I don't know too much about green
jobs but I'm for it anything green go
green as a nation we currently get less
than 3% of our electricity from
renewable sources our renewables really
all they're cracked up to be
there's some renewables that do manage
to hold their own and pass a market test
Robert Michaels is an economist at Cal
State Fullerton in other words you got
close to a third of the power in Maine
is being generated by biomass conversion
in other words there's a lot of logging
and lumbering there there's woodchips
and scrap you burn them and it's the
same as an ordinary power generator and
that's been around forever but wind
energy currently the most significant
renewable costs a lot more to produce
than conventional sources of electricity
like coal and natural gas wind energy
cannot exist without the federal
production tax credit or something
similar mark folky is the Southwest
Regional Director of annex Co a major
player in the wind energy industry the
production tax credit is about 25
percent of the economics you name your
stereotypical big business evil lobby
the American Wind Energy Association is
right up there with them a person like
me who's in the renewables industry
would argue that the fossil fuel
industry has also is also enjoy subsidy
subsidies for wind and solar on a per
megawatt hour of energy basis they are
about
20 times the amounts of subsidies for
ordinary conventional fuels in addition
to tax credits and other forms of
subsidies renewable energy companies
benefit from something called a
renewable portfolio standard a renewable
portfolio standard sometimes called a
renewable energy standard is a mandate
that the utility purchase a certain
amount of renewable electricity more
than 30 states currently have some kind
of renewable portfolio standard in place
and as those states are discovering it's
far easier to set renewable standards
than it is to comply with them the
enforcement of these by the way is also
very funny because in a lot of states
utilities get penalized for not meeting
them and then they could build their
customers for the penalty because it's a
legitimate cost they can pass through in
2002
California set a goal of 20% renewables
by 2010 what actually happened was that
there are so many barriers to the
building of renewables in California
transmission to reach them that as of at
least 2008 California was getting a
smaller percentage of its electrical
energy from renewables than it was in
2002 California currently gets around
15% of its electricity from renewables
well short of its goal of 20% by 2010
undaunted the Golden State has set its
sights even higher the industry as well
as policy makers are planning for 33% by
2017 and that is really the new 20% of
Joule and in his 2011 State of the Union
address President Obama set an even
loftier goal for our nation by 2035 80%
of America's electricity will come from
clean energy sources
that may well turn out to be an overly
ambitious goal we'd all be better off of
course if someone were to invent a new
way of producing clean inexpensive
electricity for all we know it'll be a
there's a six-year-old girl out there
playing with LEGOs that's going to
invent the new battery that's going to
help integrate more renewables onto the
grid and really sort of introduce the
game-changing technology will propping
up an industry that can't compete in the
marketplace to lead to a breakthrough
maybe what we can be sure of is that
whoever does develop a game-changing
technology will become extraordinarily
rich and as market advocates points out
if what we want is more innovation the
lure of a big payoff is a better
incentive than a government handout
there's some basic research you can make
a case for subsidizing it this is for
commercial stuff and this is where I say
you can trust mirik and ingenuity in
business and you can trust the capital
markets to put up the funds necessary
for anything that seems like a
reasonable project and what about the
promise of a green jobs revolution as
far as green jobs are concerned right
ask yourself the phone California has
had much stricter Pollution Control laws
and much more tightly enforced laws than
other states for a long time where are
the jobs that that generated it's my
opinion that renewable energy really has
the potential as a job stimulus package
somebody has to pay their salaries and
that means that money is going to have
to be collected from some people whether
it's as taxes whether it says higher
utility bills and that's money that
doesn't get spent on other stuff and in
California a state already bleeding jobs
higher taxes and electricity cost will
make it even more difficult for
businesses to survive of course you have
to realize there are people in other
states who are gonna do just fine
who are going to be taking business away
from California's industries the idea
that California is a one-of-a-kind tech
incubator is going down the drain real
fast
unlike all of the tech stuff that came
simply because entrepreneurs put up
money for it this is basically just a
set of welfare programs